you know who i think the most dangerous
man right now in the country is
well okay that's hyperbolic i should say
that but you know what you you want to
know who i think is
one of the most dangerous people in the
country dr fauci uh you know oh yeah
but but let me tell you exactly why he
is going out saying
that even if you get the vaccine nothing
will will change
you still have to social distance you
still have to mass you still
you still can't reopen your business the
people that are saying
that the vaccine will not do anything
for us
are telling people not to get it and
that's fouchy doing that
so i talk to people and i ask my friends
are you gonna get the vaccine they're
like why what's the point
and i'm like what do you mean what's the
point so who cares foul she said
nothing's going back to normal
and i'm like why is this this guy saying
these things
he's making people not want to go and
actually take care of themselves
well he was telling people too in march
2020 nobody believes me and then i say
here's the article
oh you can go on a cruise ship
everything's fine so if you look at
anything that he said the guy is kind of
an 80 i think jordan schnachtl or
whatever i'm really bad with names
um as you'll learn is actually people
thought it was a bit where i'd
mispronounce names to be like alpha
and like no i just really don't know
names i just really am that bad
and there fauci has just fallen upon his
entire government career
he's actually not an impressive person
when you watch him talk
more than one time beyond all he can do
is talk in buzzwords oh you know the
world's not going to turn to normal
talk about math talk about the numbers
talk about the models you gave
he's not going to do it and like you
said he he unintentionally
presents a case against vaccinations
because you're like ah do i really want
to do this i was on the line
nothing's going to change anyway i'm
going to keep doing and that that's
government though i mean the the lesson
of corona
honestly man was you know you watch
those movies
independence day the world rallies
together competent people rise up
you have a kind of a solution to things
our technocrats are just
idiots they're they're just not even
competent being technocrats
and fauci is a great example is that's
who we'd be ruled by
i'd rather be ruled by biden to be
honest than fountry if i had to choose
yeah well he keeps contradicting himself
even recently with the mask thing he
said
there's no evidence that you should wear
two masks now he says you should wear it
hold on the first thing he said was it's
just common sense that two masks would
be better yeah then he came out later
said well there's nothing saying that
two masks would be better
then he came out again saying two masks
are better and then the cdc is a
guideline saying where two masks yeah he
also said that all
the the vaccines will be available for
everyone by april he now changed that to
june he was telling everyone not to wear
masks he was talking about
airborne transmissions he was talking
about so many things that he was
absolutely
wrong on and yet he's still being played
by brad pitt he's still being portrayed
as some kind of religious
god figure to some people i mean the
worship of this man is
absolutely sickening they have to though
which is go to your point your point
earlier
the you know michael mal says that which
is the propaganda wouldn't be necessary
if they're
winning it's just so unbelievable these
people are so dumb
think about how crazy it is that fauci
literally came out and said
he he fought he said this don't wear a
mask he said no you don't need a mask
you don't need to go do that and then he
came out later saying oh you gotta wear
a mask then he came out saying wear two
then don't wear two then wear two
now the cdc says where where to wouldn't
any
regular person like you you described
mike who just wants to go home spend
some time with their kids
eventually be like i can't take it
anymore
you can't tell me what is going on or
why and you keep changing everything
at a certain point you'd be like there's
no way you expect me to do both
over 30 people are um so that's the
divide i noticed is
there's an outdoor gym because orange
county is pretty much life as normal
where i live
because the sheriff's like we're not
going to ticket people and arrest people
for
you know governor newsom sorry i'm not
going to do it so we have an outdoor gym
and the boomers rarely wear their masks
except you have to when you check in and
you check out the under 30 people in
between their little sets they're
wearing the masks
so the majority of the people especially
if you're not even red blue but just a
majority of people are done with it
majority of the people are what do i got
to do okay do i got to wear a mask to
check in i'm going to check in it but
they don't actually respect falci
but you go to la you go these deep blue
areas 30 year old people they're
they're actually enforcing imagine being
a 30 year old man
and you're yelling at someone to wear a
mask or right or you're you're you're
wearing a mask
and then you lift your mask up take a
bite of a cheeseburger and then pull the
mask down
while you chew and you're getting food
bits all over your mask like some kind
of [ __ ]
that's it that's insane to me evidence
that covet exists in ice cream and just
let it go right past you because your
cognitive dissonance like it's in the
food supply
my point about fauci is that i don't
expect the average person
to do all the research that i do every
day right they're not
researchers they're they're plumbers
they're they're custodians or carpenters
or computer technicians or managers or
car salesmen whatever
i i work all day reading the stuff so i
know and then many people come to this
show to try and get a critical
assessment because
that's not their job right i wouldn't i
wouldn't think i could go on the
internet and learn how to be a plumber i
can try and do a tutorial i'm going to
hire a plumber to be honest i need the
expert to do it
so what i'm saying is there are people
who could you could turn the tv
on and you have anderson cooper sitting
there with his glasses and he's like dr
fauci you say don't wear a mask and
fouchy goes don't wear a mask don't wear
them
and it's like no no no that was crazy
you need to
then he comes out later saying to wear a
mask then he comes out saying two
then don't wear two then where to then
the cd says where to
wouldn't a regular person at some point
just be like i don't even know what's
supposed to do anymore because they keep
changing what i'm supposed to do
i think that's where they are though i
guess that's what that's what i've
observed is that
that's where the average kind of regular
person is
and it's only the people who live in
these information silos
the the woke kids in brooklyn or because
again that
just as a metapoint is i remembering a
30 year old man
you if you'd told me to wear a mask and
i was probably more liberal when i was
30.
i would say what are you doing like do i
have to do it i guess i will because you
got to do what you got to do
me being being a man and yelling at
another man
when you're walking outside walking your
dog you need to wear a mask is is
another
bigger bigger problem but if you look at
just
public sentiment public cinema is where
you is people are people are kind of
tired of it have you seen that video
where there's a woman she's in a she's
in a store
and there's a guy basically harassing
her and it reveals everything when he
goes
does anybody else think it's it's it's
messed up that she doesn't have to wear
a mask but we do
right now you know what the guy was
really mad about he's mad that they got
his their boot on his neck
and he can't do anything about it so he
harasses some five foot tall woman who's
not wearing a mask
yeah crabs in a bucket um crabs at a
bucket mindset they don't want to
they don't want to do it but everybody
has to do it they're going to do it but
yeah cinnamon sentiments changed man
people are mad
that's why they're doing more and more
of suppressing information that's why
people like the new york times
unfettered conversations are happening
this is bad you don't like you shouldn't
have to scold people
if your message is credible because most
people can kind of observe the world
like you even if you work
and you work hard and people tell you
okay man-made global warming is caused
by carbon emissions and you're like okay
but wait but you're flying a private jet
you have a beachfront property you're
buying vet property but wait a minute
you're going to be
water here in martha's vineyard and you
spent 15 million on your home
so there's such a disconnect between the
messaging from the ruling elite
and how they actually live their lives
that more and more people are frustrated
do you think these regular people
who are kind of just like getting
shocked out of the system because the
media is full of it do you think they're
they're going to reject all this
wokeness because it kind of feels like
it's just sweeping over everything like
the critical theory and all that stuff
well that's why they're again trying to
push it in an educational thing
that's why the media is pushing it so
hard and having their little purges
because
you know because we read media even
though we read it critically we're
gaslit we're still victims because we
still think this is over represented
because that's what we look at all day
even even to say like this is wrong
we're still like
for so for example if you read the
internet i'm a pretty like hated guy
right
oh yeah i get recognized almost every
day even in even these little smaller
areas i go and it's always positive
even if it's negative a guy just kind of
like laughs nobody actually
really thinks i'm a scary person people
would be like oh certain
school you know kind of like one of
those but nobody but on the internet i'm
like a very very
scary guy but that's gas lighting that's
not how people actually think
in microcosm that's the same thing with
the macrocosm people are like this is
a lie one of my favorite things is how
if you right now state
you've tweeted before you're in favor of
universal healthcare right yeah yeah
pretty you know yeah i could i g people
are like oh andrew yang universal income
i'm like well you can read a political
article about me in 2017 where i was
talking about universal basic income and
my problem with that more was like the
incentives it creates versus the idea
that i think it's good to give poor
people money but that's far right
you can you can come out and publicly
state
10 left-wing positions and then
criticize
critical race theory and what will
happen to sound
wikipedia people will say hey mike
cernovich has a whole bunch of left-wing
populist positions and they'll say well
he's not a good
source you can't use him as a reference
is there a credible article
and then you will tweet critical race
theory is a bad thing and they will use
it and say well he said it so it's what
he believes he better include it he's a
far
right alt-right whatever what you say
only matters if it's bad for you
if you're saying things against the the
cathedral well yeah
what the cathedral does though is that
again that was part of the gaslighting
so the gaslighting is that
if you're me and you believed the
internet because you read the news even
though you know the news is a lie you'd
be like oh man you know people don't
really like me
and then you're like where are these
people you know literally where are
these people i've walked down manhattan
never had i've been in the most populous
like lefty areas
and i get the el chapo kind of irony bro
like luthornovich or something like that
nobody's like oh my god that's a scary
purse because the the idea when they
carcature in the media which is so funny
is
if i were a scary person you would not
write about me
right you don't see these people these
woke boys in brooklyn
writing about actually scary people like
prison gangs not writing about children
yeah exactly they're not right about
charlie habdor they're not even writing
about like even these people are like oh
yeah there's all these
you know racists everywhere then go
write about the aryan brotherhood
go knock on the door ms-13 yeah yeah go
write about ms-13 so if they were
actually afraid
then they wouldn't even write about it
so that that again translates to
everything which is
the media they they lie so much that
even when you're criticizing them you
still have a form of
a victimization of your mind because
you're like oh yeah this is predominant
opinion
no this isn't this isn't even
predominant left-wing the critical race
theory thing is not even predominantly
left-wing
i went to portland i was actually kind
of worried went to parks i've been to
berkeley berkeley
was was was kind of creepy but i walked
around with berkeley with no problems at
all
although someone did try starting a
fight with me at a skate park which is
crazy and then some other interview but
i went to portland
portland is like antifa central and i
was worried i was like i'm gonna get
some someone's gonna yell at me
and guess what happened so this guy
starts walking up to me and i'm like oh
man oh here we go
and he walks up and he goes oh it's in
pool nice to meet you man shakes my hand
and he's like big fan i love what you do
and i was like i appreciate it and i was
like is that like do you think a lot of
people in portland feel that way he's
like oh yeah definitely a bunch of my
friends watch your stuff
and i was like oh that's really neat i
go to a restaurant i'm sitting at the
bar
and i order like a spicy chicken and
bacon i'm like i'm all excited and the
guy brings my sandwich out it looks
amazing and he goes hey aren't you tim
pool
and i went oh i can't eat this now this
guy and then he was like i'll be right
back and i was like oh dude what
he comes out and he gives me a free
bottle of hot sauce he's like dude i
love your stuff man it's fantastic
and i was like oh wow thank you and i'm
like it all these people online who say
all these nasty things
where are they unit it is it's really
simple actually
what the internet has done let's say if
let's say every city in the country
let's say
let's say there's 100 cities and 60
percent of the people in these cities
are regular middle the road people and
then 30 percent are more politically
active liberal or conservative but
still fairly normal and then you have
one person who's
crazy extremist that one person goes
online and finds the one person in every
other city
and creates a network of 100 people to
harass you you then start feeling like
there's a large
coming after you but when you go out
these places most people are like oh
yeah i heard about you yeah cool how's
it going
and it's just totally normal do me a
favor guys tweet out some love to tim
and mike and luke
i don't i don't care because it's i
think the la the crap the negativity
gets shouted out because
you feel it you're angry it's easy
you're motivated but the love
it's important that you send that too i
just i've been on ayahuasca too many
times
like i've i've been confronted with all
of the things known and unknown
by god like telling me this is what you
need to work on
so then when people on the internet are
like nipping at me
it doesn't on an emotional level it just
doesn't have any kind of
like and i gotta say something too like
there's no need to do that i don't check
my mentions maybe like once or twice
periodically if i tweet something and it
shows me the tweet and the thing you
know messages come in
but i why do i care about what like you
know
some anime cat girl on twitter thinks
about what i should do with my business
like this person with 14 followers who
says dumb things i'm like you're doing
great for yourself i think i'll take my
own advice on this one
well what it does though is yeah i guess
to your point is
it it does gaslight you a little bit
where it doesn't like i don't
oh man there's a lot of people there not
being mean to me you know i'm really sad
but it's more like wow i'm a really
hated guy
you start to believe it right because
that's all you see like wow man people
really do hate me
and because i'll be a shut-in where i
hardly ever leave my house and then
leave my house people like oh man love
your stuff blah blah blah
so it it it does create this kind of
construct where
you because you only hear one messaging
even though emotionally it doesn't
regulate or
mess with you that's true though there
was a really funny moment where uh you
retweeted something from me
i i tweeted something and it was not i
can't remember what it was but it wasn't
like super pro trump or anti-trump it
was a political thing that was like
cultural
and i thought it was more like a
libertarian issue it was something about
freedom free speech
you retweeted it and then some lefty
started responding
saying like look at all the people who
are responding you all of these you know
far right whatever
and i was like i said something like uh
people retweet tweets like i don't
people follow whatever they want to
follow
and they said if you really did believe
in freedom then you would have left-wing
people coming in here and commenting
and then all of a sudden there were like
50 to 100 responses from people who
follow me
saying oh yeah i'm a liberal i follow
tim we just don't tweet we like mind our
own business right
regular people aren't trying to scream
at you on the internet
and so what do you see online the
lunatics the ones who are screaming the
loudest and that i gotta be honest that
includes each and every one of one of us
in this room
we are more more likely to be egocentric
or narcissistic than the average person
that's that's a fact
that's a good point that you're making
here and i was going to add that to ian
also just like negative comments hurt
you too many good comments hurt you as
well because they build up your ego and
this perception and this identity
that you're you're perfect and you have
no imperfections and that everything you
do
your farts smell like roses no matter
what you eat uh no matter how many taco
bells you go to
it doesn't matter but i i think for the
most part the internet is a negative
place you're not getting a lot of people
saying like dude i really love you
you're so fantastic you get them
sometimes
but angry hate but it's the same thing
though where
if if you go through life and you get
like good service or something
you rarely write like a thank you card
to the person because one of the
exercises i did early on
um when i was an angry guy maybe 19 you
know you do these at home dvd or cds
that's how you had to do it and one
exercise was like a gratitude exercise
so if you went to the airplane
and like somebody was really nice to you
you would write a letter to the manager
but it was like a good letter
like say one good thing about antifa
oh they have a lot of money
i don't know that's a compliment so i i
will say i'll say this actually there
was a guy
he actually went to jail went to prison
he attacked someone
outside of one of my events in new york
and he apologized to the guy he attacked
he still felt morally justified in what
he did
and he said he didn't regret it but it
was more like oh i didn't realize i was
hitting a civilian you know kind of
thing
oh wow but when i read his stuff he
wrote with a great level of sensitivity
in a great level of empathy
but he believe he just believes things
about the world that aren't true
and that's again where they they read
things on the internet they don't
actually talk i'm like hey dude you can
give me a call bro
like you can give me a call and you can
say hey mike do you like believe these
things before you want to riot
and i'll honestly tell you what i
believe or what i don't believe so
some of them do have uh above average
amount of literacy above average amount
of compassion above
average amount of cultural awareness
midwifes
but you know the the the thug element
you know because if you're like white
and you want to be
in a gang you join in tifa because you
can kind of get away with it right is
that it's like a life hack
do you want to be violent you can join
the hell's angels which
you're actually around really tough guys
and that maybe you're not tough enough
to do that
or you can join in tifa and you have a
license to
to beat people up and you're going to
even be defended by merrick garland
though there you go
celebrities will endorse you in support
so the the i i'm i'm partly kidding with
the antifa thing but i've said it a
couple times because
i i really don't like what these people
have done a lot of them the violence
but i also think it's really dangerous
if we only ever go down the path of
demonization we have to recognize
these people you know the saying goes
that the left
the right thinks the left is misguided
but the left thinks the right is evil
and we need to make sure that there's
always i think there's always a path to
redemption
well i think typically there's a
tendency towards a path redemption some
people are
just like it's too far gone and you're
like you know i don't know what we can
do for this person but i look at a lot
of these activists and i
i had a conversation with an antifa guy
in berkeley he was
screaming at like some right-wing dude
and i was filming
and then once things started to calm
down i asked him you know tell me what
was going on what were you saying he
started explaining he's like oh so this
guy's here and i'm saying this
and then we started walking back down
towards the park where they were doing
that rally
and he was like these people are all
fascists man you got to understand and i
said you think these people are all
fascists
and he's like yes i do and i said do you
think these people love the second
amendment
he's like well yeah of course i was like
why do you think they love the second
amendment
they're always complaining about the
government trying to take over and i was
like
well that sounds like they're scared of
fascism and he was like
wait what i mean no they're fascist and
i was like bro i think they're
scared of fascism as you are and he was
like oh
i'm like that's that moment he no one
ever told him that so maybe maybe
there's a chance to like you know these
people aren't getting real news like
naomi wolf right
she's getting this bad information and
then she goes on tucker and she's like i
can't believe how wrong i was and i'm
like
thank you very much welcome to the fight
that's that's the right thing to do or
they could go to boeing they could go to
boeing's house there's just so many you
could go to the raytheon ceo house they
wouldn't even know there
yeah that to me is why all of this stuff
is sort of empty
is at least when they were doing the wto
protest in seattle
okay okay you're actually fighting the
system you're actually fighting the
establishment
i don't agree with your tactics i don't
agree with writing but hey i can
actually see that
but going to disrupt andy knows book
sale
of paul books is to me just okay you're
not you're not fighting the system bro
right right he's just like he's dude
he's he's the child of immigrants who
wrote a book he's one guy he has no
institutional power
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time